l'objectif est plutôt simple je veux
vous aider à sortir ce qu'il y a
là-dedans et à en éclabousser votre
toile pas d'inquiétude ce n'est pas
sorcier
c'est pire que ça le monde merci d'être
venu dans cet endroit spécial avec moi
et de sa toile Carl narconne
coupé cet arbre était probablement trop
grand je parie que vous allez recevoir
des tas d'appels les gens ne vont parler
que de ça
[Applaudissements]
entraîne la peinture vers des lieux une
explorer même si tu l'as emmené dans
plein de main droite bonne soirée à tous
je l'avais encore jamais vu aussi en
plus tard
faites-moi t'amuser ne laisse pas la
gloire faire ressortir le pire en toi un
homme digne de ce temps ne regarde
jamais en arrière c'est les nouveaux
sacs que tu as commandé ça vu que les
tiennes se vendent pas on a essayé ça
vous avez de la chance que je sois un
artiste et pas une femme capable de dire
des méchancetés à une autre femme vous
avez été un artiste
la vie est un tableau
un vrai art doit suivre son cœur mon
uber est arrivé je sais pas
du tout c'est un adieu il ne pouvait pas
peindre comment vont les sources
extrêmement bien quelle est l'image
nichée dans un coin de votre tête
meurtrie votre cœur et
[Musique]
vous donne l'impression que votre âme
est sur le point d'exposé
carl est sans envergure et très sexiste
je sais que je me fiche de ce que les
autres peuvent penser de moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est au courant que Carl veulent les
journaux je vous mets en attente
[Musique]